people unfortunately and this might be
you can keep this or not keep it it's up
to you but this might be offensive to
some people are looking for shortcuts to
wealth because then they're not wanting
to put in the grind and the hard work
they're lazy if any of you sorry they're
lazy yeah I wasn't gonna use that word
but yeah you learned nothing hey guys
before we start this episode I know that
it's titled like millennial millionaire
I want to make it clear that's not why I
had him on this episode I like the
message that he preaches I do not
someone who believes you need to make a
million dollars to be successful or to
feel a sense of self-worth I don't even
think that should be your goal at all I
think it should be providing value to
people I think it should be finding a
skill that you like that you enjoy that
you can work but I think Todd has a
really interesting message which is an
old-fashioned message save money be
frugal work a nine-to-five job be smart
with your investments so don't get
overly focused on the numbers he talks
about stick with the principles I think
the principles that he shares are really
valuable and can help a lot of you so
without further ado here's Todd Baldwin
the Millennial millionaire guys welcome
to coffee Zilla today we have Todd
Baldwin this is another episode of real
jobs yeah you may have seen Todd he's
kind of been in the news lately you were
in CNBC's make it millennial money or
something like that I don't know how to
say it it's a tongue twister yeah so I
was on CNBC make it millennial money and
for my episode they dubbed it millennial
millionaire Oh a little nice and on that
show you have to like verify your income
where it's coming from things like that
right it's pretty extensive yeah
absolutely so to get on CNBC naked I had
to provide them bank statements tax
returns lease agreements mortgage
statements they wanted to see a snapshot
of my 401k they wanted to see bank
accounts where I got that money where it
was coming from it was it was pretty
crazy all like dare I say invasive but
it's good that they vet
on the show because of course I've been
getting a ton of people dealing me
asking for financial advice guys you you
know I won't invite just anyone on real
job but I'll tell you why I love Todd's
story it's because number one he's not a
guru number two he made his money in a
way that you and I normal people can
replicate maybe not the exact same way
but it's the old-fashioned grind and
save am I getting that right yeah
absolutely now I will say one thing and
it I need to say this because I did get
a little bit fortunate in the career
that I chose I took a job in sales which
they pay you not just for your time but
also on results so from a pretty young
age by the time I was 22 I was able to
make a pretty good income for my job
what job was that exactly basically I
was selling commercial insurance so if a
company wanted better health insurance
better employee benefits for their staff
that's what I helped them get so I was
basically consulting with these
businesses in the greater Seattle area
and by the time I was 22 I was I was
making six figures so that was very
helpful
that's that is super helpful but for
four people let's just talk about
commercial insurance what did you get a
college education to do that or no so I
actually I did go to college but I ended
up dropping out actually so I dropped
out of college when I was 22 I'm not
advocating that anyone go do that school
just wasn't for me I I got way more
value out of working and doing
internships at in the actual classroom
and I got approached by this company
based on some sales internships that I
had done previously and they wanted me
to come work for them so I made a
decision to leave school and go work for
them and the rest is history you busted
your butt you're making six figures by
the time you're 20 - but now a lot of a
lot of guru stuff like that would call
that the nine-to-five right that's what
you're trying to escape you're trying to
go become an entrepreneur everyone wants
you to quit your job go but you didn't
do that how did you make your money yeah
so no I I definitely I kept the
nine-to-five keeping the nine-to-five by
the way was how I bought real estate and
that
that's what's made me a crazy amount of
money both in cash flow and appreciation
but no honestly having the day job the
banks that are lending you money to buy
real estate they want to see your pay
stubs they want to make sure that you're
gonna be able to pay those loans back so
yeah you don't don't quit your day job
before you before you make it you know
somewhere else and let me say this to
you being a professional investor being
an entrepreneur I know that nowadays on
Instagram there's Lamborghinis and jet
planes but frankly it's not that
glamorous like yes I'm a millionaire but
I live with two roommates I Drive my
wife and I share one car which is a
ten-year-old Ford Focus like we don't
have a rolls-royce or anything cool like
that so keep the day job until you have
enough income from your business to
support yourself but even you know it's
hard to get there is what I'm trying to
say yeah yeah yeah yeah sorry I'm not
shedding a tear I I had something get
stuck in my eye right what you're
talking so I know but it's both because
of the fact that I'm so happy to finally
have someone on here - speaking
common-sense to the people but it's also
because I got something stuck in my eye
I could not agree with that more look
people hate common sense if it's common
sense that cost them time and the truth
is I think as you're trying to say
there's not a shortcut to wealth
it's about grinding saving assets
building assets building your net worth
keeping costs low real quick let's just
jump into that frugality how big of a
thing was that to your success that is
everything I mean so I live in a duplex
now and we have three roommates and we
went on the other half but before buying
this house my wife and I lived in
another house that we owned in that
house we had six roommates and we share
one car and if we're ever gonna go out
to eat I pretty much get that paid for
with secret shopping which is probably
topic for another time but um yeah I
mean frankly and this is something that
most people how much do you pay to live
where you live I don't pay anything to
live where I live actually
because I have roommates and I Airbnb
the other half bike to get paid 1800
bucks per month to live in my free house
that I must be doing something wrong
here cuz we def me my wife we definitely
still pay a mortgage yeah well it helps
to have a duplex and and I will say this
I'm not gonna live with roommates
forever quite frankly in the next couple
of months we'll probably know more to
live with roommates but we'll still have
a zero dollar mortgage because we're
gonna still Airbnb the other half of our
duplex but when you're talking about you
know building wealth
having no mortgage is huge it's gigantic
and so when people look at you and they
go oh man you're a millionaire how'd you
get there working a nine-to-five that
everyone says I should quit it's because
of stuff like this you're not paying
into the same thing everyone's paying
into you were smart you bought you
bought somewhere you knew you could rent
out you got roommates and you're renting
out the other side of it so you're
winning on all those fronts have you
always been this frugal where'd you
learn how to do this yeah I mean I've I
was raised by a single mom who basically
I watched her struggle money was always
tight I saw a lot of fear in her eyes
every day so I got my first job when I
was 12 and ever since then I've just
been incredibly frugal because I knew
that the life that I wanted for my
family was just a more lucrative one
than the one I had growing up and I have
a lot of respect and admiration for my
mom so you know that's there and I
respect the hell out of her but um I
definitely wanted a different life for
my family moving forward yeah yeah I
really think the biggest takeaway I'm
getting from this is you're a guy who's
who's looking at at the world
differently from other people most
people are only thinking about income
you're thinking about net which is what
actually matters you're saying how can I
win on the income side get a job in
commercial real estate start buying our
commercial insurance start buying real
estate but you're also saying look I'm
gonna take care of this other side of
the equation that no one thinks about
which is out out go how much am I paying
out so tell me about your one monthly
expenses so we know you make you pay
nothing for your mortgage to live where
you live what are
your other costs sure so pretty much
just to give everyone a full scoop so I
have six rental properties and from
those six properties I gross about
$38,000 per month in a rental income
thank you way to go after the mortgages
taxes insurance and utilities are paid
on those houses what I net is about
12,500 per month and we pretty much save
all of that where we're not going out
and spending a crazy amount and not that
you have to live like a miser your whole
life we just we don't have kids yet
we're you know we're still in our 20s
we'll start having fun when we're you
know probably 29 or 30 well as one will
be able to splurge a little bit but no I
just um we save pretty much eighty
percent of our income and it's all
because we you know we oh yeah I saw
your eyes get big for most people
they're lucky if they can flip that
they're lucky if they can save 20% of
their income right so now here's the
thing it's about sacrifice though like I
I definitely I sacrificed the first half
of my 20s well my friends were out you
know scouring hot chicks and the onda
parties and stuff I was working and
saving money so we could buy real estate
and now we're just saving a crazy amount
of money just being frugal sticking to
the principles and one thing too and I
know that I know that not everyone out
there will be able to generate passive
income that's not beyond me I know that
I'm in a privileged position but if you
are one of those people that can
generate passive income if you can
always just live below that you'll be in
evident like infinitely wealthy if you
can just live below this passive income
that's training for you every year
because you'll you'll never run out of
money that way that seems to be the side
of the equation that people neglect is
living below your means they're like I
said they're always thinking about how
can I make more money but making more
and more money number one not everyone
can do it let's just be let's just be
honest not everyone has that that that
ability number two it's a sacrifice in
your time you're always trading time for
money so if you can bring those costs
down I mean that's huge but I like what
you said about you know sacrifice
because that's something
everyone can do if you're at home even
if you don't have enough to put a down
payment on a rental property you can
still bring your cost down and start
saving money putting it into stocks you
know I know we're in a bit of a downturn
right now some would say that the stocks
are under priced right now this is a
good set for some people it's a good
time to buy so talk about people about
how you can bring your expenses down
sure so I mean one thing it's when
people are trying to budget they're
looking for things that they can cut out
and for me I've actually found that if
you find legitimate secret shopping
companies you can bring down your budget
without cutting anything out so for
example any time my wife and I go out to
a restaurant we're pretty much getting
that for free because we're secret
shoppers now if you're not interested in
signing up for that then I would just
say you know reduce those expenses just
you know just limit the time you go out
to movies there at oak there are so many
free things you can do for fun like
taking a walk you know on the beach is
free and it's fun and it's quite frankly
a lot more fun than going to some like
arcade or whatever we're gonna spend all
your money so there's a lot of stuff you
can do for free and just you know even
board games at home on a Friday night
it's it's still fun and if you're not
spending any money doing it right right
right right
secret shopping what is yes for those of
you us who don't know like me sure so
basically there are a lot of businesses
out there like restaurants and movie
theaters and hotel chains and those
businesses want to know how their staff
are doing and basically with the public
things of their products so those
companies oftentimes will hire secret
shopping firms to hire independent
contractors like you or me
to basically go pose at those
establishments as normal customers buy
their product or service and then when
we get home we fill out a report online
takes about 10 minutes and then you
usually get reimbursed for your whatever
you bought plus some money on the top so
the most recent one that I did I took my
wife out to a Mexican restaurant
we were reimbursed I believe 67 dollars
for our meal and then we were paid $10
on top of that so it's basically a free
date night Plus making 10 bucks
hey that's not too bad what do I sign up
awesome well that specific one is called
reality check and I actually just posted
a YouTube video showing all of the
secret shopping companies that I work
with that are legit and that's something
really important you guys because if you
go out in Google mystery shopping you
might come across a few scams
I started secret shopping in college
like five years ago so over those five
years I've developed the list of all the
ones that are legitimate and and the
ones that I've paid me so I know they
legit I know they're not scams
now before I I want to get this on the
record tell me you're not gonna put
these this kind of information behind a
paywall like these these daggers tell we
tell me we're not gonna see the Todd
Baldwin fake guru course coming out in a
year please tell me that here's what I
will say first of all all the stuff I'm
doing about secret shopping in real
estate I'm putting it on YouTube for
free so anyone can go watch that at any
time and here's what I will say about
paid courses and I'm not I'm not gonna
mention any names but frankly the vast
majority of them are garbage you know it
and I know it the vast majority of them
are not real there are some good ones
out there but but here's what I will say
let's say that I didn't become a
millionaire
through real estate let's say that I
became a millionaire through playing the
piano okay let's just say that for a
second sure if I generated a course
teaching you how to play the piano and
to sell that course I stood by my
Lamborghini because I'm so great at
playing the piano that I get paid to do
that
and I'm rich because of it just because
you buy my course about learning how to
play the piano doesn't mean you're going
to be as good of a piano player as me
you might not have the same talents you
might not put in the same effort you
know you might it just not might not
work out for you that way so that's what
I will say about paid courses is there
are some legitimate ones out there I
won't say they're all bad I'll say most
of them are bad but even the ones that
are legit know two things number one
pretty much anything in that course you
can find for free online it might take
you a while but you can find it but also
it there's a dip you know not everyone
has the same DNA or talent or whatever
it is so don't be don't be scammed by
thinking or become an overnight
millionaire think about consider this
Todd got rich by being frugal and being
smart with this money
I just I'm sorry to say I cannot see you
ever going out and paying a thousand
dollars for a piece of information I can
see you finding it online for free
somehow finding a way to get them to pay
you to learn or something like that but
there's no way you know and and I've
never come across a millionaire who's
like hey the Matt way I made my Millions
is I found a million millionaire course
and I learned the millionaire course and
now I'm a millionaire I've never heard
of that I've heard maybe I read a book
I've heard you know I I grew up in a
single-parent household and I learned to
work really hard what am I missing here
ya know you're exactly right and I mean
you know these I see them too I see six
hundred dollars three thousand dollars
you can pretty much find all that
information for free but but the and I
will say this to remember not all of
these people that are saying they're
rich are actually rich and some of them
even if they are they got rich just by
selling that course but frankly look if
I I just started a YouTube channel I'm
growing very slowly I have like 300
subscribers right now if I wanted to
immediately get like 20,000 subscribers
I would go rent a Lamborghini for a
couple of hours I would hire some
Instagram models and then I would rent a
mansion on Airbnb for a day and then I
set up my webcam and I'd be like hey
guys here's a Lamborghini I just bought
and here's all these models that want to
blow me every day and this is the
mansion I live in and if you want to
find out how just pay me six thousand
dollars why is our world so screwed up
I guess cuz it works is so trash people
unfortunately and this might be you can
keep this or not keep it it's up to you
but this might be offensive to some
people are looking for shortcuts to
wealth because they're they're not
wanting to put in the grind and the hard
work they're lazy if any of you sorry
they're lazy yeah yeah I wasn't gonna
use that word but yeah and if you if you
listen to if you listen to a guy like
Gary Vee he's super real about it he's
like look if there's two ways to get
rich either you have a rich daddy or you
have to work your ass
and there's really no in-between and
obviously you save on at best and do
other things and I've been able to build
passive income that way
but don't think that going out and
spending $3,000 on some millionaire
course is what's going to do it for you
because there's no guarantee of success
even the legitimate ones you might not
have the same talents as the people that
are putting it together and yeah I mean
you can find most of the information
online for free yeah yeah and the
business opportunities are almost always
exaggerated I mean even if you do end up
making a few but like Amazon FBA is a
perfect example they're always talking
about like oh this guy made a hundred
thousand dollars in sales
everybody thinks everyone who's signing
up for that course thinks oh he made a
hundred thousand dollars no he made like
fifteen thousand dollars or ten thousand
dollars after all your expenses Amazon's
cost inventory costs your your inventory
that doesn't sell after Amazon ads
there's a million different costs that
they don't tell you about upfront
because they want you to believe that
it's oh it's that easy when in reality
as you said the Lambo is rented the
house is rented everything's rented
because they're basically trying to make
it by selling a course and they didn't
really make it by doing what they say or
say they're doing the thing ultimately
for me is this people who want to sell
really want to help the world they know
that they can help far more people by
giving that information out for free and
they know the people who need that help
need it for free because they can't
afford to go into debt getting questions
the people who haven't made it who are
trying to like get rich they know that
while they might be ripping some people
off you can get legitimately rich by
selling courses as sad as it is yes you
can and here's what I'll say just
playing devil's advocate for a minute
and I mean they're like guys like I have
a lot of respect for Dave Ramsey I think
he you know he and I may disagree when
it comes to credit cards and using
leverage for real estate but he's a guy
that's helped thousands of families get
out of debt and he does have a program
that's for sale and I you know that's
his business and I applaud
right but Dave Ramsey and a few other
people that are legitimate are one out
of a big lot of a thousand that maybe
just see an opportunity to make a quick
buck off of really disadvantaged poor
people that are that are kind of just
right for being preyed on I mean if
you're struggling to make ends meet and
then some guy tells you you can buy a
Ferrari in three months was hit with his
course of course you're gonna go into
credit-card debt to spend twelve hundred
bucks and get his material but and again
I'm I'm not saying all courses are bad
some of them I'm sure are great I
personally never taken one but yeah
that's that's what I'll say about that
so tell me so tell me this all right
let's get away from the gurus because
I'm tired of talking about him talk to
me about the nine-to-five okay talk to
me about let's say I'm some guy I have a
decent job I make like seventy thousand
dollars a year everyone's telling me to
quit my job go start a company and I
want and I want to in my life wealthy
and I don't know how to do that what
would you say to me I would say be very
cautious about quitting your job until
your company is off the ground and
here's why I think in the United States
and you can fact check me on this later
but I think there are 28 million small
businesses in the United States and I
think out of that 28 million I think
24 million of those businesses are
either losing money or breaking even
so that means four million businesses
out of 28 million businesses are
actually making any sort of profit so
now if you're the lucky few to get a
business that makes you money then
that's great and eventually sure you
could probably leave the day job but
until that happens you know you gotta
put food on the table you got to pay
your bills I would say keep that until
you're able to really take off and again
entrepreneurship isn't for everyone and
you know even things like people want to
become day traders 91 percent of day
traders lose money there's there's
really there's nine percent of all day
traders nine percent actually make money
that's insane it is yeah for me the
reason why I got into real estate and
people
money in real estate - but doing my
research the one common thing that has
created more millionaires than anything
else has been real estate so I was like
oh I'll just go do that I'll go do the
thing where most people succeed or it
has the most success versus other things
that have very little success yeah yeah
no I think that's a really intelligent
way to go about it sorry if you can hear
my dog in the background he's going over
it nuts
I think that's smart low-risk proven
methods I mean like dope go low go slow
like eventually building any kind of
wealth just happens over time most
people who are independently wealthy a
lot of them never made a billion dollars
in a year by themselves especially
starting out not an income a lot of them
they make they eventually learn to make
you know enough to save they bring their
costs down they invest they invest they
invest and then their investment does
the rest right like eventually they can
get eventually retire purely on
investments I assume that's what you
eventually want to do is that right or
do you want to just work forever yeah I
know I mean eventually what I wanted to
do is I want to own a big apartment
building so I want you know a couple
thousand units and I want that to be
basically what I do and I'll hire
management company so at that point it's
completely passive and I'm just rolling
in it but I still won't be buying a
Rolls Royce any time soon because I'm
putting all my money towards my business
and one of the things that I'll say
about you know starting a business
Emmit success rate just don't you
there's no rush to quit your day job
because so much of what you see on
Instagram you guys is fake and I'm not
even talking about the gurus I'm talking
about like legitimately guys and you can
go look this up there is a company in
Germany where they have a private jet
that never leaves the runway they have a
jet that never leaves the runway you can
go you pay $400 to go get your hair done
get your makeup done sit in this jet and
this is a figure of episode I know I got
a dude
I don't remember the name of it but we
got to look it up it's like literally a
company in Germany or something like
that where they have a private jet and
all we do is take photos of you oh yeah
okay it's a Russian company it's Russian
German Russian let's you fool your
Instagram followers by renting out
private jets for photoshoots yep
offers to our photo shoots of the
personal photographer for $244 who helps
you create the illusion of the luxurious
lifestyle usually reserved for rich
people and influencers with millions of
followers let's say that again it helps
create the illusion because you're not
going anywhere it's the illusion that
you're rich grounded private look look
at this girl you guys you guys are
getting baited boys they are they're
getting catfished by Sears come on dude
look at that golden retriever oh look at
that hot chick damn dude that's that's
gonna get a million likes guaranteed
yeah but look so this person you know
sitting in the private jet about to
board it's all fake because they're
never leaving the freaking airway and
they paid to do that it's not real its
fake dude what a bunch of losers oh my
gosh dude but but it works I mean
undeniably it works but you guys have to
realize that's the meta the meta is to
fake it so you guys buy into it think
that they're super successful so you buy
their stupid course I keep trying to
teach people you've got to learn to self
teach when you when you discover that
skill the world opens up to you when you
learn that to learn you need to go out
there and do it and not you know keep
talking about doing it I mean that's
what I keep preaching on my on my
youtube channel because I think yes
maybe there are a few courses that are
like legit but are they worth the money
I would argue not and also can you find
that information online for free yes so
why not do that I mean if we're talking
about frugality if we're talking to
people about save your money there's no
better way to save your money than to
learn to learn and that
skilled that eventually carries on
learning to not rely on other people to
figure out a skill right yeah absolutely
that's what you do with real estate
correct yeah I just figured it out as I
went along I mean it was it was travel
affair and that's scary for some people
and I've and and I will say this after
the CNBC came out by the way you're
gonna hate this I've had a lot of people
message me and asking me to create a
course and you learned nothing why are
you chasing this this this rush of like
I'm gonna talk to the guy who did it and
then he's gonna Todd's no different than
you like he doesn't have the secret
answers he was just smart just be frugal
like the answers are right here in this
video right now you don't need him to
tell you anything else you don't need
anyone else to tell you anything else be
frugal invest your money in something
like figure figure out some asset class
you want to learn like real estate or
stocks or you know anything else as long
as it's not Vegas go grind well people
and I'll leave I'll leave them with this
I mean people are looking for a magic
pill when it comes to wealth it's
actually similar to the health and
beauty industry where it's like think of
how many supplements and diet pills are
sold and like creatine and these muscle
enhancers like here's that you don't
know how it get in great shape eat right
and get consistent exercise that's it
you don't need to spend millions of
dollars figuring that out and in order
to build wealth it's like okay work your
face off spend less than you make and
then the best everything you can that's
really it I mean that that's what it
comes down to well said I don't think
you could say it any better
better than that Todd thank you so much
for coming on the people are gonna love
this welcome to real jobs today we
talked to a commercial real estate
salesman who saved his money was ultra
frugal doesn't pay a mortgage invested
all his money still secret shops on the
side and now he's a millionaire but he
grinded guys he worked that nine-to-five
which everyone hates but he worked it he
invested it
got rich the old-fashioned way and it
was a pleasure having you on top thank
you so much awesome thank you it was a
pleasure meeting you and keep making
great content
[Music]
[Music]
sakura's
[Music]